Sarah: Oh, my god... I felt like we did 1,800 takes of me
saying “Hi, my name is Sarah Meister.”
Sarah: Hi, I'm Sarah Meister.
I'm a Curator of Photography here at The Museum
of Modern Art.
Lee Ann: And I'm Lee Ann Daffner.
I'm the Conservator of Photography at The
Museum of Modern Art.
Sarah: We have 30,000 photographs or more
in the Museum's collection.
How do we take care of them?
This raises so many interesting issues, so
we thought it would be fun to do a Live Q&A
where you can send us your questions and we
can try to answer them.
Lee Ann: One thing that we might touch on
is the difference between a physical photograph
versus a digital image.
How do we examine photographs?
What tools do we use?
Sarah: “How do I figure out what it is that
I have
how I should display it or take care of it”,
“Are there any photographs that are so sensitive
that we can't actually display them?”
The answer is yes.
We'll even get into the nitty gritty of when
we disagree, how do we deal with that.
Sarah: So, please send us your questions.
You can leave them in the comments section
on this video.
Or tune in live next Wednesday and we'll
answer them during the Live Q&A.
Lee Ann: In the meantime, you can check out
some videos either on conservation or on photography.
Sarah: Or, you can take our online course,
“Seeing Through Photographs.”
Lee Ann: See you on Wednesday.
Sarah: See you on Wednesday.